[Applause]
doing gymnastics with a chronic illness
can be really difficult
my body causes me to have
life-threatening allergic reactions to
seemingly nothing so sweating or crying
can be a trigger
i've nearly died from laughing too much
with my friends
but i love being able to fly through the
air and flip and twist and spin
it's just something that feels really
free to me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is natasha coates and i'm an
elite disability gymnast
i was number one in the uk for four
years running
i have won 22 british titles and
38 british medals
[Music]
i started gymnastics when i was eight
years old at my local recreational club
and i've been doing gymnastics ever
since
my condition didn't become severe until
i was 18.
one day i went into final flight to
shock it was completely out of the blue
nobody knew what
caused it mass activation syndrome is a
rare condition that affects your immune
system
so when you get stung by a nettle you
get a raised itchy bump
that's from histamine which is released
from the mast cell
my body does that when there's no
trigger
i can be sat in my room doing nothing
nothing's changed and those cells just
switch and release all those chemicals
which send me into anaphylactic shock
so just as somebody who had a nut
allergy if they ate peanuts their throat
would swell their tongue would swell
they struggle to breathe because your
airway's shutting and you feel like
you're gonna suffocate to death and
that is a real possibility with this
condition there are some
that are caused by triggers so i know
things such as getting too hot or too
cold can cause a reaction
certain foods can be an issue strong
smells
strong emotions can be a trigger i'm
literally allergic to everything
corniche seemingly fitting
training when i became unwell
i still wanted to carry on i just wanted
to adapt to it
there can be a lot of contradicting
points between having mass activation
syndrome and
gymnastics my diet is quite restricted
i'm quite malnourished with iron and
things like that
sometimes the exercises can be really
really hard but
i enjoy building up my strength and
seeing an improvement in myself
unfortunately it takes me quite a lot
longer than everybody else that's
able-bodied
but that almost makes the victory that a
little bit sweeter
sometimes i do push myself too far and i
regret it and i end up paying for it
i have lost count of how many times i've
been in hospitals
it's way over 500 times it works out on
average every two weeks
it's got to the stage where most of the
staff know me by my first name and only
them by their first name
thanks to social media i've been able to
get in contact with people that have the
same condition
as me most of them are in america and we
have this lovely little group
of about four or five of us i'm the only
one from england and we
are constantly joking about my accent
between us and they really are like my
sisters
unfortunately a couple of years ago one
of the girls taylor passed away
she'd been quite unwell
[Music]
it was really hard um
not just to lose my best friend but
the reality of the condition that i'm
living with
because as much as you can try and make
it as light-hearted as possible it is
life-threatening and
the chances are it will kill me one day
seeing the pain that i went through when
she passed and knowing that one day
all the people that i love and care
about are going to feel that same pain
really hard thing to carry and sometimes
i want to cut myself up from the world
so when it does happen
it doesn't hurt them but i need them i
need my friends and
they need me i've had many conversations
with them about it because we're very
open
they're just happy that i'm happy with
what i'm doing and i'm really blessed to
have them
[Applause]
it's not the medals that count for me
it's the experience
i love to go out and perform and show
people that just because you're ill
doesn't mean your life has to stop
[Music]
hey everybody my name is drew bibi and
i'm here in my terrible
home studio that i've made during
quarantine
and i wanted to tell you about our new
podcast called great big story
it's got more surprising and delightful
stories just like this one
so head over to apple podcast to spotify
wherever you get your favorite podcasts
and download
great big story